♪♪
-Well, this is from a while
back, but I would assume
you're sort of like
a favorite son back in the U.K.
-Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
-There's been some --
This is an article
from the "Times."
It's a big newspaper.
-Big newspaper.
Yeah, Murdoch owns, so
he can go [bleep] himself.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"John Oliver:
the British comedy failure
who makes America laugh."
[ Laughter ]
Did you know this was coming?
-[ Laughs ]
I didn't know
that headline was coming.
[ Laughter ]
I knew an article was coming,
because they said, like,
"Would you like
to do an interview for this?"
And I thought, it'll
be on the front page
of, like, the culture supplement
of the "Times."
I thought, "That will be great.
It will be a sort of
nice surprise for my parents."
[ Laughter ]
And then I had a conversation
with this journalist,
like an hour and a half,
felt like, "Oh,
this has gone quite well.
I think we've hit it off.
I don't think I've said anything
that's gonna look bad in print."
I was actually looking forward
to it coming out.
[ Laughter ]
And then that was the headline.
And it got --
The British people
are just absolute black belts
at passive aggression,
and that really feels like
it's a compliment really wrapped
in concrete-enforced insults.
-Your first on-camera job
was you were in an adaptation of
Charles Dickens' "Bleak House."
-So, that is actually true.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what? That's true.
We do have to hammer home
that that's true,
'cause that sounds like a joke
you would make.
-It also sounds
like an offensive stereotype
about a British person.
"You were all probably in
Dickensian dramas growing up."
Sadly, I was.
So, yeah.
No one has really found this out
here other than your staff.
-Here's a photo.
-This is it.
-Yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Yeah, that's right.
This is what the President
has done to me.
[ Laughter ]
Look, there's a child
with light in his eyes there.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so...
Basically,
when I was 6 years old,
the BBC was shooting
a costume drama
called "Bleak House"
nearby my school,
and they wanted a kid
with dark hair and brown eyes,
and I was two for two on that.
So, yeah, I was in this, like,
very, very lavish
Dickensian drama for the BBC
with, like, Dame Diana Rigg.
I didn't understand
what anything was.
I didn't know
what was happening.
They just said,
"Do you want to do this?"
I said, "Is it
at the same time as school?"
They said, "Yes,
you'll have to leave school,"
and I said yes before
they ended that conversation.
Yeah, it was
a very, very weird experience.
-Here's a clip.
I believe your character's name
is Felix.
-That's right.
I was Felix Pardiggle,
and I'm an orphan.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-You may have seen the names
of my five boys
printed on a subscription list.
Felix, eight pence,
to the Superannuated Widows.
-Yes.
-Wow, really good.
Really good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-That is like one more element
of the stereotype,
is that you played an orphan.
[ Laughter ]
-It is so offensive.
If I'd spent half my childhood
up a chimney,
that's the only way
that you could make that
more reductive view
of British people.
The amazing thing
about that scene,
the only thing I remember
about it is them saying,
"Hey, you need
to act bored now."
And I remember thinking,
"Oh, that's okay.
I am bored."
[ Laughter ]
-My parents watched a ton of PBS
when we were growing up.
They watched
a ton of costume dramas.
Every one of them,
from my perspective,
could've been called
"Bleak House."
-That is absolutely fair.
That's right.
That's an
all-encompassing title.
Actually, the only other thing
I remember from that
was Diana Rigg,
who was, like, one of the great
British actresses, she gave me
aniseed balls on set.
-I don't know --
What are aniseed balls?
-You don't have
aniseed balls here?
-No.
-Right, 'cause you value flavor.
[ Laughter ]
Is anyone here from Britain?
-Yes.
-Yeah,
do you remember aniseed balls?
-I do, indeed.
-Yeah, were they pleasant
to put in your face?
-No, they're disgusting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Right. They are --
-[ Laughing ]
-They are absolutely disgusting.
-And then what --
And when you --
[ Laughter ]
By the way that's the most --
I've never seen someone
so effectively interact
with an audience member
on our show.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you were so clear --
-Yeah, yeah.
That is the way
that British people
reminisce about their past.
"Do you remember that?"
"Yes, it was awful."
"Me too."
Yeah.
-The last time you were here
was a couple of days
after Prince Philip
had passed away.
-That's right, yes.
-And now, obviously you're here
on the day
of the Queen's funeral.
-I am, yeah.
-And you're sort of our royal
correspondent by fate
more than anything else.
-That's right, that's right.
[ Laughter ]
-How are you taking it all in?
-Thanks, thanks.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a difficult day.
Craig, you're from
the U.K., right?
-I am, yeah.
-Sorry for our loss.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I didn't know her.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
You guys promised me
Craig knew her.
-Yeah, you know, basically,
whenever a senior royal dies,
I will come here.
[ Laughter ]
Just click your heels
three times, and I will be here
to give it
the disrespect it deserves.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, thank you very much.
-It's been a very weird time
in Britain.
This 10 days in forced mourning,
apparently,
has been very, very strange.
-Yes.
And one of the --
We were talking about this
at the Emmys,
'cause we're both football fans.
-Yes.
-I should clarify --
we're talking about soccer.
Which was --
they did not play any
of those games for about a week.
-They didn't.
They kept -- rugby and cricket
was allowed to go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
And football had to stop
in an act of, I think,
tangible class warfare.
[ Laughter ]
-Because of the fan bases
of those three sports?
-I mean, it's hard to --
They will say
it was for other reasons,
but I think
it was probably that.
-Yeah.
-I think they were concerned
about how football fans
would respond
to a minute's silence
and maybe they would not
be able to go the whole minute.
[ Laughter ]
But it's the interesting thing.
It's always -- the question
in their mind is always,
"Well, will they behave?",
not "Why might they not?"
[ Laughter ]
There's no introspection
or follow-up
for, "Why might they decide
to editorialize that?"
-Yeah, and then,
there's also the likelihood
of maybe a chant or two.
Or a song that could happen.
-That's right.
We do love a song, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's been
a very weird 10 days.
I think -- they had in
Morrison's, the supermarket --
#Ad.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm here -- I'm here to promote
"Clifford" the movie
and a low-grade
British supermarket.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, they lowered
the sound of the beeps
at the checkout
out of respect
for the queen dying.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, she did --
She hated beeps.
-She hated beeps.
[ Laughter ]
As if someone would've gone in,
heard the regular beep,
and said,
"Have some [bleep] respect!"
[ Laughter ]
"She's lying in state!"
"As is tradition,
a quieter beep is appropriate!"
-Super Bowl on Sunday.
-Yes.
-Is that something you watch?
Is that --
-Of course. Of course.
It's the greatest thing
to happen
to a television all year
because in most other sports,
you know, the sport
is the key appeal.
And clearly, that's not the case
with the Super Bowl.
And you can say --
You are so jaded
with what you do
during the Super --
Americans just expect
fighter jets and Lady Gaga now.
You expect that
as a baseline of a Super Bowl.
-If it's not Gaga, it's
someone of equivalent status.
But that was a bad game.
-It was not good football.
-That was a bad football game.
-Yeah.
-And yet, it doesn't matter,
does it?
'Cause Beyoncé saved the day.
-Yeah.
So you enjoyed
the halftime show?
-Of course I did. Well, I did.
As a British person, I found
the appearance of Coldplay
slightly excruciating.
Oh, gentlemen, no, you are not
what is required here.
Oh, no.
They're bringing out flowers.
That's the opposite
of the intent of this sport.
These men like to smash
into each other
until they can remember
nothing in their 60s.
Your flowers
and messages of love
are not appropriate, Mr. Martin.
I've never seen
a Super Bowl halftime band
leave the stage
and just invite other bands on
to take over.
-Yes.
-It was spectacular.
Oh, and here's Bruno Mars.
Oh, good. Here's Bruno.
And here's Beyoncé.
Even better --
Beyoncé, where's Coldplay gone?
And I thought --
There was a moment I thought,
"Oh, that's really smart.
Just leave."
-Yeah.
-And then Chris Martin
wedges his way between them,
like dad-dancing
his way between them.
-Me too. Right?
♪ Don't believe me, just watch ♪
I like it. I'm funky.
I get down
with the funk as well.
He was --
He was in the middle. Yeah.
-He was.
-He was in the middle, though.
He was trying
to take the power position.
But when you're between
Beyoncé and Bruno Mars,
you just look like a guy
in the back seat
trying to...
-Oh, yeah, like that. Yeah.
-Me too!
We're having fun as a three.
Aren't we?
As an equivalent three.
-A gutting loss
for the Seahawks.
-Yeah.
-The good people of Seattle --
-Well, they brought it on.
themselves.
-They did bring it on--
-They literally have
no one to blame for themselves.
-But as a fan, you have --
you're helpless.
You have had some crushing
losses in the past.
What sort of advice
would you give
to the people of Seattle today?
-Well, it will never leave you.
[ Laughter ]
It will destroy your life.
-Hey, that's a little --
I want "Last Week Tonight."
This is way too "Leftovers."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you know what?
I don't want "The Leftovers."
-Death comes for all of us.
We're dust in the wind
of history.
-In the end, when you're
on the death bed, you --
you probably won't even
think of that part.
You'll think of your family
and stuff.
-That's it. No, No.
What -- Look, sport --
You know, sport, it's --
Even though you know
logically
it shouldn't hurt
as much as it does,
it does, and it hurts forever.
-You had a rough
World Cup England/Germany game.
-Well, England/Germany.
So two World Cups ago...
-Right.
-...I said to my wife
before the game started,
we were --
England were playing Germany.
It was obviously
not going to go well,
and I said to her,
"Look, this game,
I think, is going to be bad,
so you should think
about something to do afterwards
because when it goes badly, you
don't want to be around this."
-Yeah.
-And so England
got humiliated,
and, like,
the final whistle sounded,
and I kind of just slumped,
and there was, like,
an awkward pause, and she said,
"Oh, you know,
it's just a game,
and I love you."
And I said,
"I need to go outside now."
And I walked.
I went to Central Park,
and I walked around the park
five times.
It took 3 1/2 hours.
I literally walked it off.
I did what, you know,
aggressive high school coaches
tell 12-year-olds to do.
Just get out there, walk it off.
I did.
And it's still with me because
it never goes away.
-It never goes away.
-In domestic football,
you're a Liverpool fan.
-I am, yeah.
-And they had a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
-Oh, okay.
-I think they just learn now.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-They weren't gonna be late
to that guy's party again.
They came desperately close
to winning the title.
And I believe the last day
was your first --
Was it the first --
-It was, 'cause you sent me
a text, saying "Which are you
more nervous about,
this game
or your upcoming show?"
Knowing what the answer to that
was, which was the game.
-I felt so bad for you
that you had to...
-Yeah.
-...be watching that game
while you're preparing
for your first show.
-Yeah, 'cause if the show
had failed,
it's like, "Yeah, okay,
shows fail."
-Yeah.
-This broke my heart a bit.
-This is forever.
-Yeah.
-How invested will you be
in the World Cup?
-You know, it just gets to
the fundamental flaw
of you as a human being.
I mean, me, but also you.
-Yes, also me, yeah.
-Because you cannot
defend the fact
the World Cup is happening
in Qatar.
And I am going to watch it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I am going to criticize it
before and after.
-Yeah.
-And who knows? During.
-But I am going to watch it.
And what does that make me?
It's some version of
a kind of lower-H hypocrite.
[ Laughter ]
-It is lower H.
-Yeah, lower H, lower H.
It's not capital H.
-No, I would never say that
of you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's the thing.
I love the product
they make so much,
just like drug cartels
make a very fine cocaine.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very nice of you to say.
Nobody ever says that about
the drug cartels.
Let's not forget that they're
making very good cocaine.
-I cannot say this enough, and
this isn't sponsored content,
the Sinaloa Cartel...
[ Laughter ]
...makes some of,
if not the best, cocaine around.
[ Laughter ]
If you're not taking
Sinaloa Cocaine --
-I will say, this is starting to
sound like an ad,
but I'm gonna let you finish.
[ Laughter ]
It does feel like this is very,
like, written marketing speak.
-I think that is the secret of
lots of late-night shows.
People do often come on
with something to sell.
For me, unfortunately, it is the
fact that the Sinaloa Cartel --
[ Laughter ]
Even as I'm doing this bit,
I'm realizing there are
other cartels
who might not find this
quite as funny.
So...
[ Laughter ]
Last time
we saw each other,
we saw each other
at a very interesting time.
We saw each other the night
after the election.
-We did.
-We were performing
for a charity event called NRDC,
a great environmental
rights group.
-Yes.
-And let's both be honest.
We we agreed to do stand-up
at this event.
We did not think that it would
be that kind of night.
-No. When I agreed
to go out anywhere...
-Yeah.
-...months in advance of that,
I wasn't thinking,
"Bear in mind,
this will be the first day
of the Trump presidency," right?
Or the president elect-cy.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was, you know,
it was a weird evening.
Comedy was not
really required...
-No.
-...that night.
-And yet, there were five --
there were five of us.
-Five comedians
basically all saying
some version of the same thing
and no one with the balls
to just go on and say,
"Let's talk about those sneakers
with the wheels in the heel."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
It was...
Usually when you have
five comedians,
you know, there's that sense of,
"Hey, what are you going to do?
Because I don't want
to do something similar."
No one was backstage saying,
"Hey, I'm going to say
how [bleep] up is this.
Anybody else doing that?"
-Exactly.
And I was also very concerned
that, you know, again,
it's a great
environmental group,
but there was part of me
wanted to say
tigers may need to just move
down the pecking order
for four years
because humans
are endangered again.
So, you know, just...
-There was a tiger --
there was a reason evolution
gave tigers...
-That's right.
That's right. Listen.
That's right. They can fight
their way back from this.
-Yeah.
-We need help.
Where are the tigers?
Marching around a zoo.
[Bleep] tigers.
That's what I'm saying.
[Bleep] you, tigers.
Where were you?
-Yeah!
-Where were you in Michigan?
-Wisconsin.
Not a single tiger.
-No tigers.
-Knocking on doors
for Hillary in Wisconsin.
-Yeah.
-I'm assuming you get asked
something that we get asked
all the time, which is, "Does
Trump make your job easier?"
-Mm-hmm, yeah, which is --
It's very hard
for people to understand
just how viscerally upsetting
that question is.
-Yeah.
-Because it doesn't.
It makes it harder.
My wife, in the past,
has had to pull me away
from entirely well-meaning
people in the street, saying,
"Well, I guess it just
writes itself, doesn't it?"
and I'll say,
"I'll tell you whether
it [bleep] writes itself or --
No, I'm talking to the lady!
She wants to know
how easy it is.
I'll [bleep] tell her
how easy it is."
[ Laughter ]
No, it's -- it's harder.
It's harder.
Because, um, you know,
it's easy to do bad comedy,
because you just
need to repeat what he says,
and that's not a joke.
That's repetition.
-Yeah.
-Whereas comedy,
especially if you want
to try and do something
that's not just happening
online all the time,
is an effort.
I'm not telling you something
you don't already feel
with every fiber
of your exhausted being.
-Yeah.
You do a lot of deep dives
on stories that are
a little uncovered,
but you do spend a few minutes,
I feel, like,
covering the Trump news
at the top of your show,
usually.
And it seems like
you pick up --
'Cause you go on Sunday,
you kind of pick up
the end-of-the-week news.
-Yeah. So we literally started
thinking, at one point --
What time do you tape?
Because it's probably
about 5:30, right?
-We tape at 6:30, yeah, but
we're done at 5:30, yeah.
-Exactly.
So, about 5:30 on a Thursday,
at that point, you have dealt
with the fire-hosable [bleep]
to the extent that you can,
at which point the depressing
relay baton is put over to us.
So, from Thursday
at 5:30 onwards,
it's our turn to open our mouth
and take that fire hose in.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to that
revolted response.
"Was that analogy necessary?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Our colleague, Jimmy Kimmel,
did a fantastic job last night.
-He did great.
Yeah, I watched him, and then --
Yeah, awesome.
He's great at it.
-Would you ever want to
host an event like that?
-No. And I don't -- It's not
even that I wouldn't want to.
I don't think it would be a net
benefit for anyone involved.
'Cause the great thing
about Kimmel, right,
is that he is obviously funny,
but also, he has, like --
you're confident that there
is this low-lying contempt
for the whole event.
-Yep.
-And you're confident that
it's there,
but he somehow doesn't manage
to poison the room.
-Yes.
-With that visible contempt.
And that is a kind of
magic trick I couldn't do.
I could not at any point say,
"It's going to be
a magical night."
I'd say, "It's not, though,
is it?"
These are some of the most
over-praised people on Earth,
and we're going to give them
shiny trophies
like they're dogs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I couldn't --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's not me. No one wants it.
-I couldn't ever imagine
you saying anything is gonna be
magical without you being ironic
or sarcastic.
-I couldn't do it.
I tried.
Sometimes even at benefit gigs.
-Yeah, we do charitable
events.
-Yeah, you're good at them.
-Oh, that's very kind.
-You have the Kimmel skill of
not ruining everyone's evening.
I really struggle with that.
The only one I can kind of do
functionally
is the "Sesame Street" Gala
because they're nice, right?
So they need a bad guy.
They need a bad cop,
and I'm willing to be
Elmo's bad cop.
So they can say, "Oh, we're all
here to have fun."
And I can say, "We're not,
actually, Elmo.
We're here to squeeze that table
of bankers at Goldman Sachs
for more money than
they're willing to spend.
Go away.
Don't be here when
the transaction happens, Elmo.
Mafia rules only here."
-Do you feel like you
have a good working relationship
with the Muppets now, based on
your time at those benefits?
-Yeah, actually. Not bad.
Like, I really love them.
The first time I met one, and I
still can't really think of it
as the puppeteer, I did
something with Cookie Monster.
And he was so funny.
And I had heard that one of the
old writers of "The Daily Show,"
Rich Blomquist,
had met Fozzy Bear once
when Kristen Schaal
was in the Muppet movie.
And he'd said he wanted to meet
Fozzy Bear.
And so he's talking to him
and he just instantly forgets
there's a guy underneath him
and starts saying to him,
"I think you're the reason
I got into comedy, Fozzy."
[ Laughter ]
-And you can feel the puppeteer,
he said he could feel him go,
"Oh, [bleep], this is one
of those conversations.
Okay. Oh.
You're welcome, waka waka waka."
But he said, he just had this
very sincere monologue
about, "I think you
fundamentally changed
the way my life has gone."
-I did a Weekend Update
feature once with Kermit.
And one of my favorite photos
at my time at "SNL,"
is -- it was during rehearsal,
and I'm just looking --
I'm giving a note to Kermit.
And it's just this picture of me
talking to him
like he's listening.
-Yeah.
-And I know the dude is right
there, and I'm like --
-It's incredible.
-Yeah.
-That is how amazing they are.
I was doing that whole thing
with Cookie Monster.
I never once did I look
that poor guy in the face.
[ Laughter ]
It's just straight like, "Oh,
I'm getting on well
with Cookie Monster.
It's a bit weird that this guy
is around all the time.
-Later you say to that guy,
"What's it like working
with Cookie Monster everyday?"
He's like, "It's me!"
-No, it's not you.
It's not you.
You seem angrier.
[ Laughter ]
-Beyoncé is also
in the "Lion King" film.
-Whoo!
-Yes. That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's --
That is the appropriate response
to the word "Beyoncé."
-Yeah.
-And that's real-life royalty,
Beyoncé.
-Oh, gotcha.
So, have you met her?
-I would drop
to my [bleep] knees.
-Oh, you would.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't.
Please.
Don't look at me, Queen.
Don't look at me, Queen!
-It is really --
She's a very hard person --
-Have you met her?
-Like, only in those very brief
"SNL" sort of, like,
passing moments.
-That counts.
-It counts,
but it renders you wordless.
-Did she say hello to you?
-Yes.
-You met her!
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I don't --
I don't care that you're sick.
-All this stuff.
These were here.
How long into the process
did you bail on the idea
of doing guests?
-Really quick.
We did two test shows.
And HBO came -- their one note
on the test shows.
"Well, you know
you don't have to have a guest.
You could just add that time
to the story."
And we jumped so quickly on that
because, again,
you are good
at talking to guests.
I am -- I would find it hard
to fake enthusiasm
for an objectively bad movie
that was being pitched
in front of me.
-The longer you do this job,
you know there's no bad movies.
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
I love watching you
interview people so much
just to see -- I can see it.
It's such a suppressed glint
in your eye of,
"Well, congratulations."
[ Laughter ]
-How dare you!
Don't give up the game.
[ Laughter ]
-"'Shazam! 2' looks great."
-No, no.
-"Coming to a theater near you."
[ Laughter ]
-It does look great.
-It does look good.
It does look good.
-How dare you.
How dare you use
a recent and specific example.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
I was -- I swear.
I -- I swear to you.
I swear, my mind was going
through a bunch of things.
And it was right in the front.
I did think,
"Not the best example."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Ii mean, yes, the best example,
but not for now.
[ Laughter ]
And then I drew a blank.
You're right. It's a problem.
-When did you make
the decision
to do a coronavirus deep dive
because you didn't have
a lot of planning?
-So, I guess the answer
to that is,
it was atypical for us
because we decided
relatively early in our week,
and we did have
something else planned.
But occasionally,
there are weeks
when if we have something
very timeless
and maybe dry
that we've been working on,
like something like we've done,
like mobile home financing
in the past,
there are certain weeks, like,
I don't know, this week,
where it's a little harder
to say,
"I know that, you know,
coronavirus
is spreading across the world
in borderline pandemic fashion,
but I really need to talk
about mobile home financing."
It's a really hard sell
to be like,
"You need to? You need to
or you want to?"
in a needlessly
contrarian manner.
So yeah, so we decided at
the start of our working week,
and so we crashed it
pretty quickly.
-And how do you feel right now?
Do you think that
we are suitably panicked?
Do you think
we're over-panicked?
-As people?
-Yeah.
-It's on a person-to-person
basis.
It depends --
Like, from a scale of 1 to 10,
it depends what your regular
level of panic is on a good day.
-Yeah.
-Me, I'm at a regular 6 or 7.
-So...
So this, you probably
have to go up a notch
from wherever you were,
but not too much.
That's the thing.
You've got to try and balance.
Basically, just don't be
an idiot either way.
-Yeah.
-My my wife is very
germ-averse to begin with.
-In general, right?
-Yeah, in general.
Right. Whereas I'm not.
So I think most of her stress --
-I love germs.
-I can't get enough of them.
-Just looking
for super immunity,
licking poles in the subway.
-That's the way I feel.
-[ Shouts indistinctly ]
-I feel pretty strong
about that.
I feel like my --
But that's the thing.
She's always calling
and she's like, "Where are you?"
And I'm like, "I'm at dinner."
She's like, "No, you're not.
I can see you outside.
You're in the gutters." Yeah.
-"Are you in Times Square again,
inhaling around Elmo?"
-[ Laughs ]
So, yeah, I think
her bigger concern
is, like,
what I'm going to bring home
as opposed to, like, her, yeah.
-I think everyone's
going to have to wrestle
with their darkest,
stupidest instincts.
When my phone went off
with that news alert yesterday
of someone -- now
there's a case in Manhattan,
a woman who's got coronavirus
and she's self-isolating,
there was that initial
split second of "Where is she?"
[ Laughter ]
I've never kind of reached
for a flaming torch
that wasn't there, but...
And then I shut that down.
I shut that down
like a human being.
But there was that
split second of "Burn her."
[ Laughter ]
-I also feel this --
I've always felt this way --
-I hope you're fine.
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
-I hope --
-That goes without saying.
-I realize --
in self-quarantine,
and we shouldn't burn her.
-Yeah.
We actually do --
Our ratings are almost best --
The demographic
we do the best with
are people who are
self-isolating.
-That's right. That's right.
Emotional shut-ins.
That's why I like this show.
-[ Laughs ]
You know that thing
where whenever someone
gives you a stock tip,
by the time it gets to me,
it's too late?
-When does anyone
give you a stock tip?
Seth, I know
you're a busy guy, but --
-I always have lunch
at steakhouses.
Yeah, exclusively.
I take a full three-hour
steakhouse lunch.
No, but, like,
even when you see it, like,
I can't believe when people
watch CNBC or, you know,
like, if you're watching
the news and a guy's saying,
"Buy this stock,"
it's too late.
-Yes.
-Right?
I feel the same way about when
people say stock up on rice.
Like, by the time I hear it,
the rice is gone.
-That's right.
No question. Yeah, no question.
If ever advice is going out
that you know you are
walking into the Duane Reade,
it has empty shelves.
-Yeah.
Like if I went now,
I'd come back with, like,
one orange Gatorade.
I'd be like,
"It's all they had left, honey."
-That's right.
I don't think -- Yeah.
For the stock market or for,
you know, basic human hygiene,
I've never moved fast enough.
-Yeah.
-No one has ever given me
a stock tip.
-You know, I really --
now, I shouldn't have told you,
'cause when they give me
the tips,
they're like, "Obviously,
don't tell people.
"Don't tell the other talk show
hosts that we're giving you
these sweet --
these sweet, sweet tips."
-I just don't know
how I'd react
if if a stranger came up
and said,
"Do you want a stock tip?"
No!
Leave -- No.
And if a friend told me,
"Would you like a stock tip?"
I'd say, "We're finished."
-Yeah.
-A stock tip.
-I give people John tips
where I go.
"Don't tell him about stocks."
-He doesn't want
to hear about it.
-Welcome back.
-It's very nice to be back.
-It's been a while.
It's been a while in the studio.
We've talked via Zoom
a few times.
-Yes. It's been almost
exactly two years
since I've been in this studio.
-And if people do the math,
that's right before --
That's sort of the eve of when
the whole city shut down.
And looking back at
our interview,
do you think we played it right?
Do you think we had the
right tenor for the moment?
-I don't know how many people
here regularly watch interviews
that we do from two years ago,
but during that,
we were having some goofs...
-We were goofing hard.
-...about the fact that
the first coronavirus case
had just been confirmed
in New York City.
And goof away, we were,
you know,
slightly out of nervousness,
I think.
-Sure, sure, sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what what I was doing.
-Certainly. Certainly.
Not a zero amount
of misplaced confidence.
I remember leaving here
thinking, "Goofs well done,
fun was had."
-Absolutely.
-I got back to
my apartment building,
and there was
an ambulance outside,
and I thought, "I have [bleep]
misjudged this situation."
Oh [bleep]
-Yeah.
-And it hadn't even been on TV.
I was literally sitting
at home thinking,
"I don't even want to watch
what I just said,
'cause I think things
have shifted a little."
So, it is very nice to be back.
-Yeah.
-And I'm going to be
very careful with how
confidently
I'll predict anything
while sitting in this chair.
-I think it's very wise
for both of us
to get well out of
the prediction game.
-Yes. It is nice. It is nice.
♪♪